et pour évoquer à ce sujet avec nos
gérard espère conférencier en
géopolitique chercheur associé à la fée
mots et fondateur du site le monde
décrypté points comme monsieur vesper ma
venue bonjour alors on va rebondir avec
vous sur le sonore convient d'écouter
des manuels macro non plus président
français qui évoque le cas russe la
russie alors qu'il est en visite en
pologne cela veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que voilà on évoque
l'europe centrale et on évoque l'europe
de l'est a et entre les deux donc il y à
cette situation ukrainienne donc qui
agace tout le monde je pense pas que la
russie soit très satisfaisant satisfaite
pardon à de dépenser des sommes pour
aider les personnes aux dômes basse donc
voilà tout le monde a intérêt à trouver
une solution à cette situation là et en
étant proche au se rapprochant en tout
cas de la frontière russe
le président de la république française
a été évoquée effectivement 7 à demi-mot
cette situation un vrai manuel mâcon on
l'a entendu qui a dit ni pro russe ni
anti russe mais pro europe macron qui
dit aussi que la russie est un voisin
mais ne fait pas partie de l'union
européenne
est ce que le président français et veut
faire passer un message par ses propos
le message de il est en place depuis
déjà longtemps le message et au dialogue
donc j'ai eu le plaisir d'être chez vous
lors de la visite au fort de brégançon
n'est ce pas de lumière poutine donc il
y a déjà de nombreux mois qu'il ya un
dialogue qui essaye d'être instaurée par
la présidence française avec la
présidence russe pour une détente au
niveau du continent européen
non aucun intérêt ne pas regarder en
face c'est ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron
qui dit également qu'il n'a pas intérêt
à laisser des conflits gelés les
conflits avec la russie est ce que cela
veut dire que certaines choses m remis
sur la table
écoutez déjà le dans le cadre du groupe
de minsk une étoile il ya eu un certain
nombre d'avancées vis-à-vis du conflit
détention en ukraine
donc il faut que cela continue il
à des échanges de prisonniers il ya eu
un désastre cessez le feu cessez le feu
pratiquement respectée donc il faut
aller dans ce sens et donc il faut
continuer les rencontres soient
bilatérales entre le président vienne
ski et puis vladimir poutine ou bien une
nouvelle réunion je crois qu'il est
prévu en avril
au niveau du groupe de minsk des propos
des mêmes à mâcon qui ont été tenus lors
de sa visite en pologne
est ce que la relation bilatérale entre
la pologne et la france
est-ce qu'on peut la qualifier de très
dégradée à l'heure actuelle je pense que
les choses ont toujours deux visages
n'est ce pas et donc il ya eu une
détention dans le passé il ya eu
l'annulation d'un contrat presque à
thillois qui dans le domaine des
armements donc des hélicoptères caracal
plusieurs dizaines qu'on traque était
annulée par effectivement var se vit
donc c'est à créer une saine tension
quelques années plus tard se dire
actuellement à il est question que la
pologne rejoignent le projet
franco-allemand de chars de combat du
futur donc le mgc s donc voilà pour les
vous les choses vont un nouveau rythme
et avec des ouvertures polonaise à vers
l'europe ne faut pas oublier que sur les
450 6 milliards d'euros que l'europe
consacre de 2014 à 2020 donc au fond
dead irait cinq fonds qui existe 80
milliards sont pour la pologne
donc la pologne et le premier créditeurs
si je puis dire de cette aide
donc cela nécessite effectivement de
leur part aussi une certaine analyse est
ce que c'est une mission délicate une
mission peut-être conquête pour un
manuel macouin reconquête non pas mais
je crois qu'il s'agit d'un apaisement
d'aller au fond des choses sur un
certain nombre de dossiers que vous avez
évoqué le nucléaire l'armement d'autres
axes sur l'environnement bon il faut pas
oublier qu effectivement la pologne est
un grand producteur de charbon
donc c'est quelque chose de difficile
pour eux donc il faut toujours essayer
de comprendre
les raisons du point de vue de l'autre
si la pologne est aussi réticence à
l'immigration faut pas oublier que sa
population diminue qu'elle n'a jamais
été confronté à des contacts avec des
populations africaines ou asiatiques
comme le reste de l'europe aux turcs
comme l'allemagne
bon donc vous voilà la pologne a été
dans un écrin et maintenant l'écrin
s'ouvre et donc que c'est un peu plus
difficile à vivre pour eux il faut le
comprendre et on évoquons cela est bien
on arrive à trouver un terrain d'entente
ils ont deux jours pour le faire merci à
gérard vespière d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes conférencier en
géopolitique chercheur associé à la fée
mots et fondateur du site le monde
décrypté pas encore merci merci